what I want to deal with is a common
objection raised from the Hebrew Bible
Muslims claim that the Quran is actually
closer to what the Old Testament teaches
concerning the nature of God than the
New Testament and even though some
Muslims will deny that the New Testament
presents a Triune God still they believe
that the Quran actually is closer in its
understanding of God God's nature his
actions than the New Testament concept
or even trinitarian Christianity and
they often like to appeal to certain
passages in the Old Testament to prove
that God cannot become a man well what
does that do to our belief if we believe
that Jesus Christ is God who became a
man but the Old Testament says God can't
become a man that means our belief is at
odds in direct opposition with the Very
Old Testament scriptures that Jesus
himself confirmed to be the word of God
so you see why they employ the strategy
now notice what I said they're going to
try to quote the Old Testament to prove
that God cannot become a man now what
passages do I have in mind well let's at
some of these passages and again
trusting the grace of the Lord Jesus by
the power of Holy Spirit to enable me to
do justice in interpreting and handling
these passages
correctly the first passage that's often
quoted happens to be numbers
23:19 got to clear up my throat W that's
what happens when you have coffee right
uh numbers 23:19 here's the passage and
this is always quoted you know just
watch enough Muslim debates and you're
going to see that this passage is quoted
ad nauseum ad infinum and this is what
it says numbers
23:19 God is not man now the Hebrew word
for man here is Ish because there are
various words for man in the Hebrew
language one is Ish another is Adam
these are two common words which we
which are commonly translated in our
translations as man God is not man or
God is Not ish that he should lie or a
son of man that he should repent has he
said and will he not do or has he spoken
and will he not fulfill it now notice
God is neither a man nor a son of man
now do me a favor Chris since you have
your Bible with you turn quickly to John
8:40 if you don't mind how does this
affect our view of Jesus being God In
the
Flesh remember what the text says God is
not a man the Hebrew word for man is Ish
nor is he a son of man and yet when we
go when we go to uh John 8:40 Jesus
identifies himself as a man
in the Gospel of John 8:40 what does the
Lord say says here uh as it is you are
determined to kill me a man who has told
you the truth that I heard from God
Abraham did not do such things did you
catch it as it is you seek to kill me
this is Jesus speaking the words of the
Lord Jesus Christ a man who's told you
the truth he's heard from God a man but
wait God is not a man and Jesus says he
is a man now read John 5:27 okay um we
have and and he has has given him
authority to judge because he is the son
of man now notice Jesus Christ again
referring to himself says I'm a Man I'm
the son of man but wait numbers 23:19
Chris said God is not a man or is he a
son of man so then how can we affirm the
Incarnation that Christ is God In the
Flesh if the very foundation of the New
Testament because if you read the New
Testament clearly the foundation of the
New Testament is the Old Testament how
can we affirm the Incarnation if the
very foundation of the New Testament
denies God becoming a man or a son of
man well I'll I'll address that but let
me look at a couple more references that
repeat the same point there are other
references that say God is not a man 1st
Samuel 15:29 1st Samuel
15:29 and also the glory of Israel will
not lie or repent this is again speaking
about God he's the glory of Israel he
does not lie he does not repent for he's
not a man Hebrew word Adam so he's not
ish he's not Adam he's not a man that he
should repent and then finally hosiah or
however you guys want to pronounce it
Hosea 11:9 it says for I am God and not
man ish the Holy One in your midst and I
will not come to destroy so these
passages if you read them clearly seem
to deny so again I said clearly seemly
right contradiction terms but you'll see
why just a surface level reading of
these passages would leave a per person
with the impression that God is denying
the possibility of becoming a man
therefore our belief in the Incarnation
directly opposes what the Old Testament
teaches now with that said I'd like to
begin addressing this objection so Chris
are you with me I'm With You by by by
the grace of the Lord Jesus Christ right
okay first of all if you actually read
the passages and if you read them
carefully God is not saying that he
can't become a man during the Old
Testament period no Christian believes
that God had become human had become a
flesh and blood being
uh human being in fact during this
period God existed as an unembodied
Spirit we believe that later in time he
became flesh at what specific point when
the Eternal Word who's fully God in
essence came down and took on a human
nature and a physical body by the power
of the Holy Spirit from his Blessed
Mother you know Mary the Mother of Our
Lord while she was a virgin because we
affirm like Muslims do the virginal
conception and birth of our Lord and
Savior Jesus Christ but during this time
during this period of of of God's
revelation to Israel God had not become
a man so it is true God is not a man but
it doesn't say God will not become man
God cannot become man that's reading too
much into the text let me read the
language carefully God is not man which
Christian would deny that during this
time in in Revelation or salvation
history God had not become a man he was
an unembodied spirit and as such it's
true he's not a man but beyond that the
point of the passage is not so much
whether God is Man or whether God can't
become man the point of the passage is
that God is unlike man in his
fallenness because of Adam's sin after
the fall human nature is characterized
by sin and imperfection so the point of
God in in saying these statements is
that I'm not like man therefore you can
trust me unlike man I am reliable unlike
man I keep my word so this is actually a
statement about the fallenness of
humanity the corrupt sinful nature of
man God is saying he's perfect he's holy
he's righteous unlike man who's
imperfect untrustworthy unreliable and
capricious let me read it again that's
the point of the passage numbers
23:19 God is not man that he should lie
do you see that now this is very this is
a a this is not a very positive
description of humanity God is saying
unlike you humans I don't lie in other
words humanity is characterized by sin
by unreliability by capriciousness by
deception by Lying by imperfection and
then he goes on to say nor am I a son of
man that he should repent so notice man
is characterized for lying and changing
his mind and God is not like man in that
sense in what sense God is not like man
in the sense that God doesn't lie nor
does he change his mind so it's not so
much a statement of whether God is a man
or whether God can become a man the
point of the passage is that God is not
like man in his fallenness which opens
up a
question if God were to become a man
what kind of man would he be understand
the point of the passage in fact if you
read osiah 119 and 1st Samuel 15:29
they're both saying the same thing God
is not like man in this sense man is a
liar man is imperfect man isn't CA
capricious man changes his mind God is
unlike that that's the point of the
passage not so much whether God is a man
or God becoming a man let me read 1
Samuel 1529 so L someone accuse me of
reading too much into these other
passages because it's clear from numbers
23:19 God is saying I'm not a man in
that I don't lie men do I'm not a son of
men in that I don't repent son of men do
that's the same point in these other
passages let me read 1st Samuel 15:29
lest a Muslim hearing this accus me of
reading too much into these passages
notice what 1st Samuel 15:29 says also
the glory of Israel will not lie or
repent and here's the reason for he's
not a man that he should repent see it's
the same theme man do to the fall of
Adam and Eve is characterized by
sinfulness by imperfection by compri
justness by being unreliable
untrustworthy because he'll say one
thing today but do another thing
tomorrow because he's full of
contradiction
confusion right dishonesty and God is
unlike man in his fallenness so now this
opens up the door to the following
question
Chris if God is not like man in his
Fallen nature God is not man in the
sense that man is Fallen corrupt
unreliable if God were to become a man
what kind of man would he be would he be
like the rest of human beings Fallen
corrupt unreliable capricious no if God
were to be become a man then he would be
Flawless he would be perfect he'd be
absolutely sinless absolutely reliable
lone behold this is exactly the kind of
man that Jesus was are you with me
absolutely read the New Testament Jesus
was absolutely sinless absolutely
righteous absolutely perfect in other
words Jesus Christ wasn't like the rest
of men he wasn't a man in the sense that
men lie and Jesus lied he wasn't a son
of man in the sense that son of man
repent and he repented no Jesus was man
in the sense of being an absolutely
Flawless human being so even numbers
23:19 can apply to Christ in his
Incarnation because Jesus is not a man
that lies Jesus is not a son of man that
repents so that's also true of Christ in
the Incarnation he's a man that doesn't
lie he's a son of man that doesn't
repent so even that statement is
applicable to the Lord you with me Chris
mhm because this can be said about Jesus
in light of his Incarnation Jesus the
man was absolutely perfect therefore you
can say Jesus is not a man that lies
Jesus is not a son of man that repents
because he was the type of man the type
of son of man that was absolutely
Flawless like God is because he's God
who became flesh so as it stands these
statements do not even touch the issue
of whether God can become a man and if
so what kind of man would he be he'd be
exactly the kind of man that Jesus was
because Jesus is God who became flesh
right now someone will say again well
I'm reading my new testament theology
back into the Old Testament you can't
prove that from the Old Testament that
God can become a man without ceasing to
be God so that the point of these
passages is not that God can't become
man the point of these passages is that
God is not like man in his fallenness
someone say we can't prove that from the
Old Testament yes I can what I'm going
to do with the time remaining by the
grace of the Lord Jesus Christ is
demonstrate that the Very Old Testament
scriptures the very Hebrew Bible depicts
God a appearing in human form the Very
Old Testament says God often appeared in
human form and on one occasion not only
did he appear in human form he actually
ate food as a man so the same Hebrew
Bible that says God is not a man says
that God appeared as a man and ate food
as a
man as a precursor to the Incarnation
and I let me qualify that L the viewers
misunderstand what what I'm getting at
I'm not saying that these appearances of
God in human form are
incarnations because I Define incar
incarnation in the following way
Incarnation is when God actually becomes
a flesh and blood human being he is born
as a human being and takes on an
additional nature of humanity that's how
I Define incarnation what's happening in
the Old Testament God has not actually
become a flesh and blood human being
he's not actually being born as a babe
he's not taking an additional nature and
attaching attaching it to his person
he's simply assuming human form without
actually becoming human right he's
assuming human form without actually
becoming human yet that form is so
tangible that you can actually touch it
and it feels real it's like wow
something's substantial that human form
is so tangible that Jacob could wrestle
with it and I'll show you that a minute
that human form is so tangible right
that God can actually consume human food
food in that human form now where am I
getting this from I'm getting this from
the Hebrew scriptures in fact let's go
to Numbers Chapter
12 verses 5 to8 numbers 12 veres 5
to8 and the Lord came down in a p pillar
of cloud now watch this is the same
Hebrew Bible in fact it comes from the
same section where we got numbers 23:19
this is Numbers chapter 12 verses 5 to8
same section same book same author the
book of numbers numbers 23:19 said God
is not a man that he should lie nor a
son of man that he should repent the
same author in the very same book right
when I said section because this is
written by Moses and there are five
books called the penit this is the same
section of the penit called numbers
numbers 125 to8 same author same section
of the penet same book numbers 12 5-8
and Yahweh came down in a pillar of
cloud
and stood at the door of the tent and
called Aaron and Miriam and they both
came forward and Yahweh said this is
he's talking now to Aaron and Miriam
hear my words if there is a prophet
among you I Yahweh make myself known to
him in a vision so that appear to
prophets and Visions I speak with them
in a in a dream so here we're told that
various ways of Revelation the various
modes the various ways that God speaks
to his servants
include drink dream and Visions see when
I appear to a prophet and speak to him
and give him my words and commission him
I do so in a dream I do so in a vision
all right these are the various modes
various ways that God speaks to his
servants to communicate his will to and
through them to his people well now
notice how he speaks with Moses not so
with my servant Moses right he is
entrusted with all my house with him I
speak mouth to mouth clearly I speak
directly to him
and not in dark speech in other words I
don't speak in Parables I communicate
the message clearly to Moses because
that's how honored he is in the sight of
Yahweh and he beholds the form of Yahweh
did you catch it other prophets will
will see me in dreams and vision Moses
sees me in actual time and space and he
actually beholds my form so God has a
form well by Nature God is formless
by Nature God is spaceless by nature God
is time now why would I say that because
the Bible is emphatically clear the
Bible is quite emphatic that God created
every created thing that would include
time space and matter everything and
anything that has an origin was brought
into existence by God well that would
include time space and matter that means
logically God exists before there was
time before there was space before there
was matter therefore God must be
timeless that doesn't mean he came enter
time and experience time once he creates
it it's not what I'm saying I believe
that God can enter time and experience
time right but by Nature he's Timeless
spaceless and immaterial I.E God is
formless by nature however the same God
who created all these various forms is
the same God who is capable of assuming
any form that he's made so here when he
talks about Moses beholding my form he's
talking about his visible form by by
which God can appear to people in time
and space space and they can see God in
a veiled form in a veiled expression so
here he says he beholds the form of
Yahweh